[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, everybody.
My name is Sue Ganz-Schmitt, and
I'm dressed like an astronaut
today because I'm
excited to tell you
about my new book, "Planet
Kindergarten," which
I see some of you
already have out there.
So every great mission
needs a mission checklist.
So here's what we're
going to talk about today.
Why I'm dressed
like an astronaut.
We already did that, so check.
What I do when I'm not
pretending to be an astronaut.
How I got the idea for
"Planet Kindergarten."
Who is Dylan, and
is he an astronaut?
What does Shane Prigmore know
about astronauts and space?
And finally, I'm going to read
to you "Planet Kindergarten."
And you'll be the first group
of kids that have heard this.
OK.
One of the things that I
do when I'm not pretending
to be an astronaut is I
produce musical theater.
That means I help put on plays,
like the one that you see up
there.
And that is "Peter Pan."
I've also produced "Little
Mermaid," and maybe some of you
have seen "Seussical."
And we have kids
from kindergarten
to sixth grade in our plays.
I'm also a
philanthropist, and that
means I like to
help people in need.
And our family started
an orphanage in Haiti
to help kids, to make sure that
they have a home to live in,
a good education, and
the medicine that they
need to be happy.
And you can see these
kids are really happy.
And my favorite
job is being a mom.
And these are my daughters,
Jensen and India.
You could wave to
them over there.
I brought them to my
work with me today.
And we like to have tea parties.
You can see we're having
a tea party right here.
And these are two
other books that I
wrote, called "Even
Superheroes Get Diabetes"
and "The Princess
and the Peanut."
So I like writing
books that help kids.
And "The Princess
and the Peanut"
is for kids with food allergies.
Do any of you have
food allergies here?
You do?
OK.
I wrote this book to help kids
like you so other kids could
understand your food allergies.
And because I write books,
that means I'm an author.
So I'm going to tell you how
I got the story for "Planet
Kindergarten."
And it started a
long, long time ago.
That's me when I
was in kindergarten.
And something that I loved
to do was dictate stories.
That means I used to sit down
at a table with a parent,
and they would type up the
stories I would tell them.
And I would illustrate them.
So these are some of my first
stories that I ever wrote.
And when I was in kindergarten,
something really exciting
happened.
It was exciting for our family.
It was exciting
for all of America.
And it was that the first
man landed on the moon
in a spaceship
called the Apollo 11.
And that kind of inspired one
of my first space stories.
And here it is.
I'll read it to you.
"My father and my brother
are going on a rocket."
The end.
That was it.
But great stories can just
start with one line like that.
Then a few light years
later, my daughter Jensen
started kindergarten.
And when I was there, I
was noticing the kids.
That's her on her
first day of school.
And that's her
kindergarten classroom.
But as I looked around, I
noticed that a lot of kids
were happy and excited
to go to kindergarten.
But there was one
little boy named Dylan,
and he looked pretty nervous.
And there he is.
And I invited him to
tell you in his own words
what kindergarten
was like for him.
Hi, my name is Dylan Williams,
and I'm not an astronaut,
much as I wish I were.
But I do play one on YouTube.
On my first day
of kindergarten, I
remember feeling really nervous.
But I took some deep
breaths, looked around
at my crew, my mom, my dad, and
some friends from preschool,
and I marched right into
that classroom anyway.
Turns out my teacher
was really nice.
And she knew how to help
when I was homesick,
which happened quite a lot.
It turns out
kindergarten was actually
a pretty great adventure.
And that day I also met my
very best friend, Augie,
who is still my friend today,
which adds up to eight or nine
years of an awesome friendship.
And that friendship
has really taught me
that when you have a good
friend, no journey is too big.
So a few years later,
before I completely
had the idea for the
book, we went to NASA.
And that's where they
launch rockets into space.
And we were there with Dylan.
And he dressed up
like an astronaut,
and that gave me a
great idea, I thought,
for a book called
"Planet Kindergarten."
But a picture book
without pictures
is sort of like the
Earth without the sun
or Saturn without any rings or
other planets without Pluto--
just missing something.
So I needed someone who
was really good at drawing
pictures, because
as you remember,
those are the pictures I drew,
and I still draw like that.
So I found this amazing
artist with the help
of my editor, Melissa
Manlove at Chronicle Books.
And his name is Shane Prigmore.
And you might recognize
some of these images
that I'm about to show you.
He worked on "The Lego Movie,"
"Coraline," "Megamind,"
"How to Train Your Dragon."
And these are some
of his characters
that he's helped create.
And when he was creating these
images, he researched space.
He looked into what
spaceships were
like and what types of
spacesuits they wore,
what colors you
would see in space.
And this part's really fun.
These are his characters.
And these characters were
inspired from other great space
characters, like ET and R2D2.
So that's all about how I
created "Planet Kindergarten."
And now I'd love
to read it to you.
The countdown started.
Dad and I checked the plans
for my next big mission.
My doctor gave me two thumbs up.
Mom and I got lots of supplies.
Today is liftoff.
I suit up.
Dad helps me with my gear.
What if I'm not ready?
What if we crash into a comet
or get sucked into a black hole
or even worse, my
lunch floats away?
You are well prepared, said Dad.
I'm ready to explore
Planet Kindergarten.
We arrive at the base camp, then
orbit while we look for a place
to dock.
I'm assigned to my commander,
my capsule, and my crewmates.
Don't leave, I beg.
Mom slips her photo into my
pocket and squeezes my hand.
I don't want her to
worry, so I stand tall.
Parents are sent back
to their own planets.
We're aliens from many galaxies
on Planet Kindergarten.
Our commander tells us our
flight plan for the day.
Mission Control calls
in on the intercom.
They welcome us on our journey.
I try to get used to
the new atmosphere,
but it's not like home.
For one thing, gravity
works differently here.
We have to try hard
to stay in our seats,
and our hands go up a lot.
At recess, we test the
conditions outside our capsule.
A crewmate and I
disagree over equipment.
We have to sit in
isolation, and I
learn that isolation
isn't any fun.
My crewmate agrees, and
I have a new friend.
Back in the capsule, we run some
experiments, write in our logs,
and then capture images
for our families.
I wish they were here.
At lunch, I find out
that I love space food.
My lunch doesn't float away.
But our trash will,
so we contain it.
The commander says that space
exploration makes you tired
and you have to rest.
I'm too excited to sleep,
so I count the stars.
In the quiet, in the dark,
I get really homesick.
Is the room running
out of oxygen?
Abort mission, I think.
You can't do this.
Get out of here.
I spot the escape hatch.
Then I remember what
they say at NASA.
Failure is not an option.
If failure isn't an option,
that leaves only success.
Rest time is over.
I take a deep breath,
and I get back to work.
Before I know it, my
mission is accomplished.
My parents rush to greet me.
Then it's splashdown.
I'm back on my own home planet.
Mom and dad are proud.
Me, too, because they
were brave to let me go.
I love it here, but
I'm already training
to go back to Planet
Kindergarten tomorrow.
Mission accomplished.
I think we went over
everything we set out to do,
and now it's time for book
signing and space painting.
Come get your faces
space-painted outside by stars.
And I'd be happy to
dedicate a new book to you.
Thank you.